well we're gonna miss you in Civil War
I'm gonna miss Loki I miss him a lot do
you I do I guess he's doing my personal
belief is that as God's rate with Loki
on the throne like the trains run on
time dates everything's clean
surrender tight yeah I didn't know what
he's doing we'll wait don't have to wait
and see and we'll have to wait for
Ragnarok ah indeed but Tom's I saw the
light co-star Elizabeth Olsen
will be by Captain America's side on May
6 we've seen a pivotal looking fight
between vision and Scarlet Witch yeah
I'll be able to explore their
relationship a little bit totally you do
we learn a little bit more about what
connects them in this film and I think
there's some really sweet moments
between Paul and I it's more about how
they relate to one another and their
similarities just just based on their
superpowers
yep Tom and Elizabeth are both in the
Marvel Universe but their first time
together on screen is in this Hank
Williams biopic I just felt a huge duty
and a responsibility to them and to him
and to enter the to to the keepers of
the flame of so many people who've kept
the music of Hank Williams alive and and
you and and he's become an inspiration
to so many
they don't move any
Tom's musical talents are showcased in
the film so is there a singing career
ahead for Hiddleston I don't know what I
would say think about it I'm definitely
a more proficient musician than I ever
have been as a result of having made
this film and and I'm better at the
guitar I too have recorded tracks on an
album is some it's pretty cool